My daughter committed suicide and she was 24 years old because of depression
If someone insists on committing suicide, how can we change their minds?
Well .. at first, so I'm very sorry
It is very terrible
Okay
I had this friend
Her granddaughter ..
Sorry
There is a lot of depression
In our family
So it's a question of reality
Generally
I had this friend
A friend of his parents and granddaughter committed suicide
She blamed herself for it
What could I do? What could I have done differently?
This is the problem of suicide; it leaves everyone wondering, my God, what could I do !?
I could have treated that person better
I could hear them! I could have been next to them!
She blamed herself for these
She felt that she was not a useful person and that she had failed as a child
She is a very good person
So I went to walk with her and I said
She is married and admires her husband, he is a good person
And I said
You paint yourself
Suicide on your granddaughter!
Do you blame your husband?
Do you sit down and tell him that he was very useless?
Because his granddaughter committed suicide and how he failed completely!
She said: No, I will not
I replied: Well ..
Do not do it yourself
No
People
Depression is a terrible thing
And many many things are caused by we spend it ...
We understand some of them but many of them do not
People sometimes become depressed because they are severely ill
We know that depression may be an inflammatory disease
May be associated with autoimmunity
There are many reasons why people may be depressed
Dejected people go to dark places heavily
You can not imagine it
It is not necessarily the case that you can always save someone!
But dumping yourself into a suicidal incident is not useful
So there is room for self-forgiveness
Maybe I did some things that deserved the blame I was not supposed to do
But you do not want to blame yourself
Remember the presumption of innocence
Is innocent until proved otherwise
You must apply this to yourself
I think sometimes people are so depressed that no one can do anything
This is the worst part of it, when a depressed person thinks
The depressed person thinks saying
I see only disasters everywhere
I do not see any way out
I do not see any way forward at all
Perhaps the combination of these two beliefs is what makes people
Actually inclined to suicide
The hopeless situation!
Will not improve
where ever you go! There is no escape
The agony is unbearable
I am absolutely useless for anyone
It is better for everyone to disappear from existence
If not a great burden will destroy their lives now
That burden will become that in the future
Try to imagine
This is the case for these people, it's horrible
There are so many ways to get there
So
You can listen to people
You can encourage them with every hope to ask for the help they need
I have seen antidepressants and they do miracles on many many people
They do not work with everyone
They do not consider a solution to all problems
But they have side effects
One side effect of untreated depression is suicide
And do not recover from it
This is relatively high
You can go to war with them about antidepressants
If a person can not get out of his depression he is a suicide bomber
What will he lose?
One month on antidepressants
They will teach
They may have to try it longer because they will depend on their response
Some people respond better to a class of antidepressants than others
It's worth fighting someone for it
If they are in a very bad state and will not do everything they can to improve
(ASK) Electric shock therapy is useful
Working with depression is difficult to see
It is a terrible thing to consider
But the modern methods of (ASK) are not the same as in films
And repeat, there is no return from death!
So
You can not save everyone
People get sick, they die
Sometimes the reason is unavoidable
He seems depressed
Depression is a multifaceted phenomenon
You can be by their side, listen to them
To see them
You can intervene
You can try to understand, to hold them accountable
You can do all these things
But everyone has his destiny
And you are not
Able to everything
So a disaster will happen at some point
Such as your daughter's disaster
And then
Try to come with the least burden of misery with you
On what you can
When you recover from your grief
Yup